yo creo que ahora que tenemos todas las
herramientas que necesitamos podemos ir
más adelante pero solo como un pequeño
repaso del último vídeo donde tratamos
de modelar una distribución de
probabilidad donde nos preguntábamos
cuántos carros aproximadamente pasarían
en una hora y lo primero que hicimos fue
decir bueno hay que buscar como una
intersección con la cual podamos después
encontrar una bonita expresión del valor
esperado de nuestra variable aleatoria y
esta variable aleatoria solo regresando
un poco al inicio nosotros definimos
nuestra variable aleatoria como el
número de carros que pasan en una hora
cierto y dijimos que ya sabíamos que
había bastantes horas con las cuales
obtuvimos una buena estimación a la cual
la llamamos landa entonces nos interesa
modelar como una distribución binomial
todo esto por lo que si es una
distribución binomial landa va a ser
igual al número de ensayos por la
probabilidad de éxito de ensayos
entonces lambda es el número total de
éxito
en una hora y esto debería de ser igual
a los éxitos en un pequeño intervalo
entonces esta es la probabilidad de
éxito en el pequeño intervalo y en el
último vídeo nosotros tratamos de ir
razonando y describiendo todo esto y
entonces este intervalo al principio
dijimos que lo dividiremos como por
minuto pero luego pensamos qué tal si
pasan más de un carro en un minuto
entonces ellos dijeron oh déjame ver
cómo puedo mejorar esta probabilidad por
segundo pero luego vuelve a surgir la
pregunta o el problema qué pasaría si un
carro más de un carro pasa por segundo y
entonces es muy sencillo pues lo que
querías hacer es tomar el límite
conforme éste se aproxima a infinito
conforme n se aproxima a infinito y
luego ver qué tipo de fórmula obtenemos
de las matemáticas y así podríamos ver
cuál es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a algún número la probabilidad de
que dicha variable aleatoria sea igual a
no sé tres carros en una hora particular
tres carros en una hora en específico
bueno primero tomando el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de las combinaciones
de n en k pues vamos a tener cada
momentos en el tiempo donde n tiende a
infinito y estos intervalos se van a ir
volviendo súper pequeño cierto así que
esto se convierte en momentos al tiempo
entonces nosotros vamos a tener momentos
de tiempo infinitos y este es el número
de éxitos cuando una auto pasa así que
podemos tener tres momentos y la
probabilidad de éxito es cuando un auto
pase entonces puedes tener siete
momentos durante una hora o tres autos o
tres momentos durante una hora por lo
que ahora terminando con nuestra
distribución binomial de n momento se
eligen cada por la probabilidad de éxito
y cuál es esta probabilidad de éxito
bien pega que va a ser igual que va a
ser igual a lambda sobre n cierto
entonces esto va a ser sólo dejarlo
reescribo aquí abajo que es igual a
lambda sobre n sólo estoy reorganizando
esto aquí ok entonces la probabilidad de
p es igual al anda sobre n y luego si
tuvimos acá éxitos esto va a ser l sobre
n al acá y entonces cuál es la
probabilidad de que fallamos sería uno
menos lambda sobre n y esto a que lo
vamos a elevar va a ser cada éxitos y en
total teníamos en ensayos entonces lo
que nos resta sería n menos k 1 - lambda
sobre n n menos cara y luego déjame no
cambio de color reescribiendo esto en su
forma desarrollada vamos a tener el
límite cuando n se aproxima infinito dm
factorial sobre n menos k factorial por
k factorial sólo lo estoy desarrollando
ok por landa a la k aquí va voy a usar
las propiedades de los exponentes sobre
n al acá y esto va a ser igual a 1 -
holanda sobre n a la n menos acá pero de
hecho podemos separarla con la ley de
los exponentes tenemos la misma base
podemos hacer que ambos exponentes si
los llegamos a multiplicar se sumen y
nos quede lo mismo y ahora déjenme
simplificar solo un poco más y aquí
vamos a intercambiar estos dos puede
hacer una especie de vista con estos dos
como el denominador así que puedes
cambiar el orden de la división o de la
multiplicación dependiendo como te
convenga entonces esto es igual hay aquí
este color verde no me gustó pero bueno
vamos a reescribir primero esta
expresión como lo hicimos en el vídeo
pasado vale y lo mostramos cómo sigue
quienes factorial es igual a n por n
menos 1 por md menos 2 hasta n menos
camas 1 y entonces por ejemplo si
tuviéramos que em es igual a 7
tendríamos 7 factorial sobre 7 menos 2
factorial por dos factores y tendrías
aquí siete menos 6 cierto y 6 es uno más
que 7 menos 2 y eso fue justo lo que
hicimos en el vídeo anterior por si
sientes algo de confusión vamos a
tomarlo otra
entonces exactamente tienes acá términos
aquí y ten cuidado solamente estamos
reescribiendo esto que puse en color
como rosa entonces luego al intercambiar
estos dos vamos a tener todo esto
dividido entre n al acá por al cambiar
esto por la and al acá sobre cada
factoría y luego entonces que tendríamos
aquí vamos a tener bueno vamos a
reescribir todo esto más bien a
continuar con todo esto digamos que
están sobre la misma línea
y vamos ahora sí a tomar el límite si
tomas el límite esta va a ser otra
propiedad entonces no te sientas tan
abrumado pues es otra propiedad de los
límites si tomas el límite cuando x se
aproxima a cualquier cosa de fx por gd x
esto va a ser igual al límite cuando x
se aproxima a de fx por el límite cuando
de que se aproxima a de eje x entonces
podemos tomar dichos límites de el
proceso y luego multiplicarlos y así
obtendríamos todo entonces hagamos esto
de aquí primero que todo que es este
límite déjame hacerlo y vamos a ocupar
otro color amarillo y bueno entonces el
límite cuando n se aproxima a infinito y
por tanto esto de aquí es n por n menos
1 por n menos 2 y todos hasta llegar a n
menos k que van a realizar al meterle el
límite estamos multiplicando un bonche
de binomio
y entonces lo que estamos haciendo es
multiplicarlos cada vez es cierto
entonces a lo largo este término va a
hacer n a la cada cierto más un buen de
cosas va a ser n a la k más bla bla bla
bla bla que van a ser todos estos
términos que van a estar después y van a
ser más pequeños que n al acá y en el
denominador vamos a tener en el acá soy
reescribiendo por lambda al acá pero
bueno más bien vamos a hacer el límite
cuando n s aproximada infinito pero esto
se vuelve una constante pues no tenemos
ninguna n en este término entonces
simplemente dejamos por landa a la k por
k factorial y entonces ahí si viene el
límite cuando en esa próxima a infinito
de las expresiones de abajo que es 1 -
landa sobre n a la n
y 1 - lambda sobre n a la menos k
sí ya sé que esto no se está viendo muy
claro pero simplemente estamos
reescribiendo lo que teníamos en la
parte superior entonces aquí tenemos n a
la k más blablabla una serie de cosas
pero esta parte del numerador es igual a
la parte del denominador entonces estos
dos se van a cancelar y nos va a quedar
1 entonces dicho coeficiente se vuelve
uno y otra forma de hacer esto es que
podemos dividir el numerador y el
denominador por n al acá y entonces
obtendríamos 1 más 1 sobre n más 1 sobre
cualquier otra cosa solamente hay que
dividir el 1 sobre n al acá de las
diferentes en las que tenemos entonces
este límite cuando lo metemos nos queda
1 por el límite de toda esa serie y
entonces esa serie tiende a cero pues n
tiende a infinito y uno sobre un número
grande se va a cero
entonces es uno
portland al acaso break a factoría y
esta parte de aquí hay que trabajarla
pues lo que voy a escribir en esta parte
de la esquina superior izquierda es
igual al límite cuando n se aproxima a
infinito de uno más a sobre n a la n es
igual
a la y si te das cuenta es exactamente
lo mismo sólo que aquí en lugar de tener
a vamos a tener menos landa entonces
esto va a ser igual
a la menos blanda y esta parte de acá
que va a pasar con esta parte
bien pues tenemos que es uno menos
lambda sobre n a la menos acá y al meter
el límite en esta expresión n tiende a
infinito entonces esto se vuelve cero y
entonces tenemos 1 a la menos acá y 1
elevado a cualquier potencia es igual a
1 entonces tenemos un 1 otra vez por acá
y si te das cuenta todo se reduce
bastante bien es algo bastante
entonces esto la probabilidad de que x
como variable aleatoria del número de
carros que pasan en una hora es igual a
un número en particular donde si fuera 7
si fueran 7 carros los que pasan en una
hora
esto sería igual a el límite cuando n se
aproxima a infinito de n en cada por
lambda sobre en el acá éxitos por el
número de fallas que sería uno menos
lambda sobre n a la n menos k y como lo
desarrollamos hacia un momento todo esto
se reduce a hacer la anda a la ca sobre
k factorial por ea la menos lambda y en
realidad este resultado es bastante
bueno aquí quizás no se le dé forma o no
hay fe no hay manera de poder
desarrollar con el teorema del binomio
pero no hay ningún problema tú también
tienes conocimientos acerca de los
factoriales cuando tienes un número
factorial y entonces todo esto se reduce
conforme metes el límite y en esa
próxima a infinito hacerla
líder entonces está perfecto de hecho
esto tiene demasiada semejanza cuando en
finanzas utilizan interés compuesto pues
también utilizando esta fórmula de aquí
arriba el interés compuesto tiende a
comportarse como una exponencial pero
bueno esos son otros temas y regresando
a esto en realidad sólo importa que
sepas usar dicha fórmula entonces
digamos que lambda es igual a 9 que es
el promedio de carros que esperamos que
pasen durante una hora y entonces ésta
sería la probabilidad de bueno en
realidad lambda es mi valor esperado
esperamos que pasen 9 autos en una hora
pero aquí nos interesa saber la
probabilidad de que en una hora pasen
exactamente 2 autos
esto sería igual a sustituyendo en la
fórmula 9 al cuadrado sobre 2 factorial
por ea la menos lambda que es 9 y esto
será igual a 81 sobre dos factores al
que es 2 por ea la menos 9 y sería buena
idea hacer una gráfica y ver qué pasa
con esto o meterlo la calculadora
y obtener el resultado exacto pero te lo
dejo de tarea nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo